from her early teens milakunis has built
a long and storied career as a comedic
and dramatic actor having worked with
some of the biggest names in the
industry her Evolution as a creative
mother and philanthropist has been
momentous milakunis was convinced that
she wouldn't be able to jump from TV to
film after playing Jackie Burkhart on
that 70 show believing that she would be
typ cast moving forward resolving to
leave the industry after her contract
was up she briefly attended College
while making the hit series I was very
keen on getting a college degree not for
any reason other than I thought I should
or had to cuz my whole family is college
educated Kunis attended UCLA before
transferring to Loyola Mary Mount
although she doesn't recall attending
any classes after transferring the
actress didn't know what she wanted to
study and only took classes that
interested her she ultimately wanted to
continue acting so she discussed it with
her parents and they suggested she drop
out while she decided to pursue acting
at the time she also told Women's Health
that her priority above all else was
living a happy life and as she's gotten
older she's found fulfillment in lots of
things outside of acting soon after that
70 Show wrapped milakunis had a shot at
a role in the Jud appat movie Knocked Up
while she didn't get the part she must
have had a memorable audition because
she was invited back and landed a role
in appau 2008 film Forgetting Sarah
Marshall she was cast as Rachel Jansen
Jason seagull's onscreen love interest
after his character's breakup with the
titular Sarah Marshall it was her
breakout film role and put her on set
with a cast of Comedy Allstars including
seagull Russell Brand Paul Rudd and
Jonah Hill the role was fun and racy and
Kunis embraced it all though unlike some
of her co-stars she didn't have to do
any nude scenes for Kunis the biggest
challenge while filming was trying not
to laugh at her castmates when they
joked around as she explained to movie
web I like to laugh and apparently I
find everything funny I'm just going to
go with my character laughs at it for
her next major film kunas played a
ballerina in 2010's Black Swan starring
alongside Natalie Portman whenona writer
and Vincent casselle Kunis had never
danced ballet before and was surprised
to land the role to ensure a worthy
performance she she went the extra mile
to prepare she underwent intense
training as a ballerina and lost 20 lbs
to gain a super skinny physique as she
explained to collider she practiced
hours a day every day for several months
saying you can only fake so much
physicality so you have to immerse
yourself in this world in the way that
somebody walks talks and handles
themselves while making the movie kunas
tore a ligament dislocated her shoulder
and injured her back but her efforts
made the difference Kunis was nominated
for Golden Globe and Screen Actors Guild
Awards for best supporting actress
though she didn't wind up taking them
home she didn't mind that as she told
Entertainment Tonight she still got
immense satisfaction from the work
itself regardless of critical reception
Mila Kunis and Home Alone star McColly
kulan dated between 2002 and 2011
although Kunis never dished on intimate
details she credited the relationship
with helping her not fall prey to the
pitfalls of young Hollywood she
explained to women's health I don't know
if I met him at 27 if it would have been
a different relationship we grew up
together you find a steady Rock in your
life and that's all you need we have our
ups and downs but work through them
after the couple split up kunas admitted
on Howard Stern's show that Culkin's
fans made it difficult to walk down the
street together kulen was such an
enormous star that the public seemed to
lose all composure in his presence it
wasn't like a normal response to a
celebrity he had the fans responded in a
in a very abnormal way to him this
strange Behavior may have been the
motivation for why the couple chose to
stay home play video games and eat
dinner privately for much of the
duration of their relationship although
their split was characterized as
amicable kunas later admitted she was to
blame for their breakup on the Dak
Shepard's arm share expert podcast Kunis
blatantly stated she is not happy with
who she was throughout her relationship
with kulen although neither Kunis nor
kulen ever elaborated on why they broke
up both have moved on with their lives
Kunis has been married to Ashton Kutcher
since 2015 while people reports coken
and Brenda Song have two children
together and were engaged in
2022 although she wasn't interested in
the film at first kunas got roped into
making the romantic comedy Friends with
Benefits opposite Justin Timberlake as
kunas told Vanity Fair she wasn't
particularly excited by the script when
she first read it but after she joined
the cast she got the opportunity to
rework it alongside Timberlake and
director Will Gluck Kunis explained that
in the process she and Timberlake would
improvise scenes and Gluck would then
rewrite parts of the script based on
their performance the actor told the
publication that this was the first time
she got to experience this element of
the filmmaking process saying it was the
first time that I felt in my career ever
to be part of a collaborative process of
doing a rewrite still Kunis admitted
that Timberlake's Fame posed a challenge
while filming on location she explained
that while in a studio it was perfectly
normal and that the young Timberlake was
enthusiastic and excellent to work with
however as soon as they appeared on the
street fans would mob the pop star
turned actor his level of Fame
overwhelmed Kunis but this experience
may have prepared her for developments
that would soon transpire in her
personal life Kunis and Ashton Kutcher
both ended long-term relationships in
2011 and the former co-stars reconnected
in January 2012 at the Golden Globes on
Mark Marin's WTF podcast kunas admitted
she noticed him first and that it took
her a moment to realize that the man she
was checking out was actually her former
co-star although they agreed to date
casually kunas realized a few months
down the road that she had developed
feelings for Kutcher after learning he
was seeing someone else she resolved to
end their flirtation if Kutcher didn't
feel the same and went straight to Ker's
house to confess her feelings the next
morning Kutcher appeared at her front
door and asked her to move in with him
although kunas feared he wasn't ready
for such a big step after ending his
marriage to Demi Moore Kutcher made it
clear he wasn't willing to risk losing
kunas they moved in together in April
2012 and got engaged in February 2014
not long after kunas told Ellen
degenerous that they were expecting
their first child by the time bad moms
came out in 2016 kunas was expecting her
second child in the film she plays a
frazzled mom who's over involved in the
lives of her two school age children
with a combination of help and push back
from her friends played by Kristen Bell
Katherine Han Christina Applegate and
Jada pinket Smith she learns to let
loose Amy PTA meeting at T will we see
you there no bye
it was a lesson kunas felt applied to
her life offscreen too speaking about
the film she told today the reason I did
the first one is because I related to
the ideals that I put on myself I tried
to be so perfect I literally drove
myself crazy with my first kid it made
me feel like okay you're not a failure
Kunis's follow-ups to bad moms such as a
bad mom's Christmas and The Spy Who
dumped me were also comedies however her
work after those saw her transform again
as the next films she got involved with
involved very serious
performances in an extremely sharp turn
from her several year stint in comedies
Kunis opted to take a role in the
supremely dark four good days in the
film kunas plays Molly a heroin addict
who must stay sober for four additional
days after completing a 3-day Inpatient
Detox to qualify for an opioid blocker
injection that might change the course
of her cycle of addiction and save her
life the film gave kunas an opportunity
to showcase her range as an actress
while co-starring with the incomparable
Glenn Close who played Molly's mother at
the 2020 Sundance Film Festival kunas
acknowledged that she used to naively
believe addiction was a choice choice
and that she made the film because her
perspective on addiction had shifted she
explained you learn and you grow and you
see life evolve around you you realize
that's not the case and I thought that
this film was a beautiful depiction of
that I wanted to Deep dive into it
because I also wanted to understand what
makes an addict an addict both milakunis
and Ashton Kutcher have been involved in
philanthropic causes in the past but
after Russia invaded Ukraine in February
2022 the couple started the GoFundMe
campaign stand with Ukraine to raise
funds for humanitarian efforts in the
Alien Nation the campaign partnered with
flexport and Airbnb to distribute
supplies and fund short-term housing for
displaced refugees speaking with people
kunas claimed that this was one of the
only times she's felt the need to speak
out about her humanitarian work as she
wanted to ensure the word got out to as
many people as possible she shared how
after Russia invaded Ukraine she
received calls from people asking how
they could help the GoFundMe came about
as the result of she and Kutcher
figuring out the most efficient way to
assist in such a critical time for us it
was what's already in motion that we can
put money towards that we know ourselves
kunas and ker committed to matching $3
million to get the donations rolling and
thanks to their efforts kunas landed on
people's 2022 people of the year list
and Time magazine's 100 most influential
people of 2022 to date The Campaign has
raised over $37 million however kuna
certainly didn't do it for the accolades
stating I've never been more proud to be
from Ukraine I'm so honored my kids can
carry on that Heritage in 2022 kuna
starred in and produced the film
adaptation of just a n's novel luckiest
girl alive inspired by N's true life
story Kunis plays Anie Finelli a New
York journalist who survived a school
shooting as a teenager only to be
ostracized by her community in the
tragedy's Wake when Anie agrees to be
interviewed for a new documentary about
the shooting she revisits the night she
was sexually assaulted at a high school
party revisiting these traumas
destabilizes Annie's picture perfect
life and makes her a voice for sexual
assault survivors according to
Entertainment Weekly while much of the
film is inspired by N's real life
experiences those same experiences
informed hers and Kunis's decision to
write a completely new ending for the
film according to null Kunis embraced
being a creative producer and was
instrumental to crafting that new ending
as Kun is told Entertainment Weekly I
know the ending is polarizing which is
what I think makes this movie so
interesting a lot of people didn't like
it but I fought so hard for it to stay
in I'm really glad that we won this
fight because it's so powerful in 2007
kunas told parade that the thought of
reprising her role as Jackie from that
70 show wasn't on her radar she cited
the still recent conclusion to the as
the reason behind The Stance though she
also stated that a ways down the line
she might be open to a reboot it seems
her instincts were spoton for in 2023
Kunis and Ashton Kutcher reprised their
roles of Jackie and Michael and returned
to Point Place Wisconsin for a brief
cameo in the sequel series that 90 show
kunas felt that it was important to
support the spin-off of the series that
launched their careers and Kutcher even
told Esquire that she was the driving
force behind their decision to appear in
the show kunas was also outspoken about
where her character's life went telling
Access Hollywood that it felt out of
place for Jack to end up with Kelo you
know what I called BS I was like my
character would be with Fez I think that
I ended up with wilmore's character
while making that 70 show muna's
audition to voice Meg Griffin on Family
Guy after the original voice actor Lacy
shabar dropped out of the series over 20
years later kunas has done Voice work in
over 400 episodes of Family Guy and her
long-standing relationship with the
Animated Series has led to other voice
roles kunas has lent her vocal chords to
characters on wonder Park helenback and
Robot Chicken she is also Al close
friends with Robot Chickens co-creator
Seth Green and expressed to collider how
proud she is of the show's success and
recalled that she's seen it evolve from
some of its earliest and most
rudimentary iterations she is also an
executive producer and voice actor on
Stoner cats an adult animated series
with an All-Star cast about sentian
house cats living with a woman who
combats Alzheimer symptoms with
medicinal cannabis the web series
recently made the news when the SEC fil
charges against its creators for illegal
sales of $8 million in unregistered nfts
the production company agreed to stop
selling selling the nfts and pay a $1
million civil fine although it neither
admitted nor denied any wrongdoing in
the matter in the summer of 2023 Kunis
and Ashton Kutcher wrote character
letters in support of their That 70s
Show co-star Danny Masterson to a judge
presiding over Masterson's sentencing
hearing for his two rape convictions in
response some have criticized the way
Kutcher and kunas characterized
Masterson as a role model and brother
figure as tonee and hurtful to his
victims after these letters elicited a
major backlash Kunis and Kutcher
released an apology on Kutcher's inst
account explaining how Masterson's
family asked them to write the letters
in an attempt to clarify the intention
of their efforts legal action center
deputy director Colleen McCormack
maitlin told box that character letters
are not a rebuttal against a conviction
saying the point of these letters is to
help the sentencing judge understand who
the person is beyond what they might
have read in an indictment or heard in
testimony at trial because of public ey
about the perceived insincerity of the
coup's apology Kutcher resigned as the
board chair of Thorne an anti-child sex
abuse organization he co-founded in 2009
in turn Kunis also resigned from her
position as an observer on the board if
you or anyone you know has been a victim
of sexual assault help is available
visit the rape abuse and incest National
Network website or contact Reigns
National helpline
at800 656 hope 800 656
[Music]